what's going on guys this is rob and
rumors are circulating out there that
apparently thanos is returning to the
marvel cinematic universe that josh
brolin is i guess bringing back or
coming back with cable and thanos now
honestly these are just rumors right you
guys know how this kind of thing starts
right like somebody out there mentions
it somebody out there mentions it and uh
specifically this was a tweet that was
sent out by binge watch this so honestly
i haven't really been doing this game
long enough to know whether or not binge
watch this is like a reliable source of
information right or if they're like we
got this covered where just nobody
believes them i don't really know if
that's the case or not but as i saw that
it kind of got me thinking right because
i saw a whole bunch of responses to this
tweet
and in all honesty
i'm in that school of thought right from
people who were just kind of like
no right thanos need to come back here's
the thing i love the character of thanos
in the marvel cinematic universe right i
love the way that he was done in some
ways i think he was kind of an idiot
right like blinking out half the life in
the universe and then like in a thousand
years we'd be right back to where we
were before so we just didn't really do
anything meaningful but it was a stopgap
measure uh but at the end of the day in
terms of like his philosophies and like
just his his kind of just imposing
presence and so on i love the way that
he was handled
but in my mind the reality is that
thanos's story has been told right like
thanos has done and as much as we love
to see him return i think what that does
is it takes away from the opportunity to
see better villains because here's one
thing to keep in mind and the grand
scheme of what the marvel cinematic
universe could do because i had somebody
ask me this recently right like how long
do you think these movies can go on for
the the the kind of i guess trend of
making comic book movies that will end
before the marvel cinematic universe
runs out of content to make movies on
right like i mean just one thing to
understand this this is those of you
guys who who don't read comics the first
10 years of the marvel cinematic
universe that's a six issue story arc in
marvel comics right or or maybe an event
right maybe like a 12 issue event or
something like that right you get all
the origin one shots and then you
basically get tie-ins for everything
that's going on and like the main event
itself which might be like six issues
that's it right i mean there really
isn't a whole lot doing there right so
maybe more like 18 issues but the
important thing here is that's a very
small number of issues just to give you
guys perspective here the the civil war
event itself in marvel comics was like
110 issues long and that was one event
right so we're talking about the first
10 years just being a minuscule amount
of time in relation to comic book
storytelling now extrapolate that out
imagine all the events that have ever
been covered in the history of marvel
comics operation galactic storm maximum
security the onslaught saga age of
apocalypse the cree scroll war like the
evolutionary war all that kind of stuff
like there's all kinds of things out
there and those events are or sometimes
colossal in scale and sometimes they're
relatively shorter then there's all the
individual character story arcs the
marvel cinematic universe can make
content for hundreds of years so the the
trend of interest in comic book movies
will die out long before the mcu runs
out of content to make but the important
thing here is there's a lot of ground
that they could cover there
would it be cool to see thanos return i
guess and i could see him returning in
relation to like a flashback or maybe
even in a tv series because one of the
things that we didn't really get from
like the whole thanos the whole infinity
saga that i always wish we'd gotten was
an origin story for thanos i mean we
kind of got one to a degree right then i
was like well you know on my world on
titan it was lush and nice and then
basically people just started
procreating with reckless abandon and
never gave any thought to the to the
consequences of doing that and then
basically killed my world so in order to
prevent that from happening from across
the cosmos i'm just going to blink out
half the life of the universe right and
that'll basically be it right he's like
you know people in my world did what
like humanity will have done in like a
hundred years basically you know so i
mean it's it's okay in terms of like an
origin but like an actual tried and true
origin story something akin to like
thanos rising right something akin to
that story arc in movie or tv form i
always wish we'd seen that but in so far
is thanos being like undusted right and
then coming back i don't really know how
i feel about that right i feel like
thanos's story has been told and so what
i think our discussion really should be
in the future of the mcu is what kind of
villains do we want to see because
here's one of the cool things to keep in
mind and we've talked about this before
or at least mentioned it and it's
something that i avidly believe the
villains are infinitely more interesting
than the heroes and they almost always
have been or at least in more recent
years i'd say since like the 1980s 1970s
1980s the villains have always been more
interesting than the heroes you can set
your watch to a superhero like there's a
person in danger well i'm gonna go put
my life on the line to save that person
but the villains have motivation they
have drive and so when you look at
somebody like thanos sure he's great but
the possibilities are endless here and
they don't all have to be on the same
level as thanos thanos is cool and in
the comics he's a very imposing figure
and in the marvel cinematic universe
having the infinity gauntlet really kind
of etched him in as just a mainstay
among all the villains in the mcu and
it's entirely possible that going into
the future he will always be at the top
right he'll always be the just just the
guy i imagine most of that would be
nostalgia because we grew up with the
first 10 years of the marvel cinematic
universe and so thanos was like the big
villains so if for no other reason the
fact that we just kind of have these
nostalgia feels we'll always say like
nobody will ever be better than thanos
like me for example i say no music is
better than the music from the 90s
there's no arguing that right it's an
absolute point i mean it's not really a
debatable thing but i also say that
because i grew up in the 90s so
nostalgia
but the thing about this is that if you
take away the power component right the
idea of thanos just being this really
imposing and super powerful guy with the
infinity gauntlet and you look at just
the nature of the villains themselves
pain the conqueror is cool i guess but
like there's way more interesting
villains out there we've talked about
this guy before william striker is just
a ridiculously
under-appreciated villain across the
board leaving out the story arc in model
comics where he blew up a bus of kids
which he did it was pretty messed up
william stryker is basically the leader
of a group called the purifiers right
this guy is a fanatic it's absolutely
crazy he's just a religious
fundamentalist this guy has no powers he
can't read minds he cannot alter reality
he doesn't have telekinesis or anything
like that he's just a really charismatic
guy who believed that it's his mission
from god to kill mutants because mutants
are basically an abomination as far as
he's concerned the story god loves man
kills right where he was initially
introduced by chris claremont back in
the day it opens up after the purifiers
have killed these kids parents and
they're chasing these kids and these
kids end up in a playground and when
these kids are like begging for their
lives they're like why are you why are
you doing this right why are you killing
us and the purifiers are like because
you don't deserve to live and they kill
them and then they string them up with
like a sign around their neck that says
muties it has obvious allegories to like
racial issues from the 1960s but like
magneto's the one that finds him and he
goes on a warpath but like the story
doesn't end with some great big huge
climactic battle like the end of
avengers in-game or anything like that
it actually ends with a debate between
cyclops and williams striker where
cyclops basically corners him right
william swagger keeps making this
argument that no no no you know mutants
are an abomination they're against god's
will and all that kind of stuff and then
ultimately cyclops is like i mean do you
believe god's infallible and the
responsibility of striker is of course
right i'm a religious man he's like then
you have to believe that if if mutants
exist then it's god's plan therefore we
were created by god and then william
striker freaks out pulls a gun and then
like he gets he gets shot by a cop right
and then like they haul him off to jail
but like when he comes back later that's
what it was really really cool right he
gets a hold of a futuristic robot so he
actually knows how things are going to
unfold going into the future and no one
knows that he has this so he just passes
himself off as this guy with like
knowledge of future events different
things like that but like the original
story was great now i'm not saying that
like a movie or a tv show needs to end
in that capacity or even open up in the
same way but what i am saying here is
that not all the best villains out there
are trying to wipe out half the life in
the universe not all the best villains
out there are from like a different
planet or hugely imposing or something
like that sometimes they're just that
damn dangerous and that's what makes
them cool if we wanted to go a little
more traditional mcu and focus on a
villain who had powers superior
spider-man is a great choice exactly how
you build into that i'm not entirely
sure but dr octopus taking over the body
of peter parker is a phenomenal story in
all honesty i know a lot of you out
there really love the idea of thanos
returning and i totally understand he
was a great character he had phenomenal
a phenomenal 10 years it was awesome
just seeing him right just the things he
was able to pull off but i feel like a
lot of the desire to see thanos return
is really based more on the things you
saw him do and the moments you
experienced in the marvel cinematic
universe as opposed to the actual
motivation and the character of thanos
himself and so what i would invite you
to do here is to experiment and i might
launch a series on this to be honest
right i may just make a series here on a
geek culture explain and just call it
villains we need in the mcu and that's
it right just make videos on like the
origins of villains and why i think we
need them in the marvel cinematic
universe what makes them cool and
interesting because there's a lot of
possibilities out there if you guys want
to see that let me know down in the
comment section let me know if that's
something you guys would be interested
right because i've got i got 25 years of
coming back knowledge just rattling up
here in the head and that's just stuff
i've read right you added the stuff i've
researched so that's
well that's a lot
it's quite a bit but nonetheless you
know just just let me know what you guys
think i feel like it would be cool but
uh with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end and uh thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace